like I've only seen two dynamics that
work in relationships over like an
extended period of time one is We're In
It Together and the other is like
cheerleader and quarterback but the
thing is is for me I know personally
like I had two very long relationships
that were cheerleader Dynamic and to me
I could not imagine living life that way
having now lived what I live now because
like there's a certain amount of shared
respect that you never get with somebody
who does not know what it's like to be
in the battlefield or in the arena and
if I'm like I need to work for the next
three days and like write five book
chapters it's not a discussion it's like
course do you think there's no like I
can't believe you're like into the flip
side in the cheerleader Dynamic a
cheerleader who's really rooting for the
team doesn't ask the quarterback to come
out when the game's on the line and so I
think that a lot of people are running
in what they consider to be cheerleader
Dynamics but they are inverted Dynamics
they're actually sabotaging the game in
that Dynamic it's harder in my opinion
to do the cheerleader quarterback
because you have to have a very aligned
mission and goals of like the
relationship